bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de votre mensuel dédié à
l'actualité politique du territoire nous
reviendrons tout à l'heure sur le
lancement du mouvement par dème dans les
yvelines par dème pour partie de la
démondialisation ils entendent restaurer
à la souveraineté nationale sa
responsable sera en plateau dans un
instant je recevrai également ressent
dream grand gaube la première secrétaire
fédérale du parti socialiste qui
reviendra et sur les rapports entretenus
entre la majorité et l'opposition au
sein de l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines il existe toujours plusieurs
sujets de discorde et puis à nous le
demanderons également sur un plan
national où va le ps alors que la
mobilisation contre le gouvernement
contre la loi travail se poursuit de
nouvelles manifestations avaient lieu
aujourd'hui 14 juin à paris notamment
avec quelques réactions pour débuter
cette émission suite au double meurtre
hier soir à magnanville un acte
revendiquée par l'état islamique et qui
intervient moins de 24 heures après un
autre acte terroriste aux etats unis
cette fois ci à orlando
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région demandent l'ouverture des centres
de rétention en ile de france
elle demande au président de la
république et au premier ministre manuel
valls de monter d'un cran la riposte
contre le terrorisme même chose pour
gérard larcher le président du sénat
sénateurs de rambouillet et qui a
affirmé de son côté qu'il fallait avoir
la volonté de combattre le terrorisme
quant à pierre bédier le président du
département je vous propose de l'écouter
au micro ce matin de mélanie poquet
c'était aux mureaux devant le
commissariat où était affecté le père de
famille assassinée
c'était indispensable d'être fière
sur place indispensable d'être là ce
matin est indispensable d'être là dans
les heures et les jours qui viennent
parce que ça fait froid dans le dos
c'est pas encore le moment des
polémiques mais il va quand même falloir
finir par se poser les bonnes questions
quand on est en situation de guerre on
cherche pas à être juste et bon on
cherche à être efficace et je
m'interroge sur l'efficacité des
dispositifs actuels
je crois que suis pas le seul je pense
qu'il ya 66 millions de français qui
pensent comme moi plat pour les propos
des principaux responsables de droite
sur notre secteur sandrine grands
groupes bonsoir vous êtes la responsable
du ps donc département des yvelines
conseillère régionale conseillère
municipale également attrapé conseillère
communautaire à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines votre réaction
est ce que vous aussi vous pointez du
doigt les dysfonctionnements éventuels
avant tout il faut déjà être dans la
compassion il faut déjà apporté toutes
nos condoléances aux familles des
victimes
c'est la moindre des choses parce qu'on
est tous dans un moment la fois de
tristesse dans des froids par rapport au
mois d' opéra thouars et il faut savoir
raison garder et réfléchir
collectivement sans être dans la
surenchère abandonné il ya une situation
nationale internationale qui les
nouvelles en fait et qui nous impose
aussi de réfléchir sur fictivement
comment on réagit le plus intelligemment
possible
moi je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut aussi être capable de dire que ce
qui nous rassemble c'est à dire nos
valeurs le pacte républicain qui est qui
est le nôtre doit être assez fort pour
justement ne pas laisser place à cet
effroi qui en fait et c'est exactement
ce qui est recherché en fait mais on
parle d'un suspect aussi qui était déjà
connu des forces de police qui
éventuellement les enquêtes le
prouveront que l'on est passé entre les
mailles du filet quelque part parce
qu'il y eu des dysfonctionnements il
faut aussi durcir le ton c'est ce que
demandent par exemple valérie pécresse
gérard larcher pierre b mais là on est
dans la communication emmené il faut
être dans l'efficacité
effectivement quand pierre bédier 10,66
millions de français sont d'accord avec
moi personne ne cautionne ce terrorisme
il faut être dans une logique
pl câble contre cette idéologie qui est
absolument mortifère après il faut
trouver les bonnes solutions les bonnes
solutions c'est pas de fichier tout le
monde est enfermé tout le monde s'est
effectivement d'être efficace et là il
ya des spécialistes il ya une politique
à mener et c'est bien d'abord de prendre
le temps de la réflexion avant de dire
n'importe quoi
autre sujet avec vous nous parlerons
tout à l'heure de la situation politique
à saint quentin en yvelines vous siégez
à l'agglomération déjà sur un plan
national comment vous vivez cette
dernière année du quinquennat de
françois hollande en tant que socialiste
puisque l'actualité aujourd'hui ce sont
ces manifestations qui sont ce qui se
sont poursuivies à paris notamment
contre la loi travail la transition est
un peu difficile puisque passe d'un
sujet qui est évidemment grave à un
autre sujet qui est aussi important et
moi en tant que socialiste on est dans
une période un petit peu difficile on va
pas le cacher ou moi je en tant que
responsable de la fédération je continue
de dire qu'il ya une voie possible pour
la négociation
la politique c'est du consensus ces deux
l'écoutent et peut-être qu'il ya des
étapes qui ont été loupés dans ce
processus là et donc moi je ne désespère
pas un moment donné de voir
la raison l'a encore l'emporter et que
l'ensemble des interlocuteurs se
retrouve le lieu qui sera le lieu du
débat c'est l'assemblée nationale et
j'espère qu'à ce moment là quand le
texte reviendra à l'assemblée nationale
nous pourrons avoir ce débat qui n'a pas
eu lieu et la première fois mais quand
on voit les manifestants qui continuent
à durcir le ton quand on voit la cgt
aussi qui est qui maintient son action
il ya même eu aussi des violences contre
les forces de police cet après midi est
ce que c'était vraiment un propos il n'y
a pas un moment il faudrait mettre un
certain temps de pose aussi c'est pas
tout mélanger et là il ya de la
contestation sociale il ya un mouvement
qui dit qu'il n'est pas d'accord contre
la loi le droit de manifestation existe
dans ce pays
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et puis il
ya des débordements mais ça c'est autre
chose via il faut traiter les sujets de
manière différenciée il y a le mouvement
social qui porte un message qui est que
la loi telle qu'elle est non
actuellement ne convient pas et qu'il
faut encore le temps du débat
et puis bien sûr la condamnation de tout
ce qui est acte violent mais qui est
d'une autre nature
le ps aujourd'hui est bien seul europe
écologie et les verts le parti
communiste par exemple qui ne veulent
plus d'alliance en tout cas sûrement pas
pour 2017
on a vu aussi des militants ps qui
attaquent le parti pour ne pas avoir
lancé l'organisation d'une primaire par
exemple aujourd'hui le parti socialiste
qui attaquent en justice afin que
justice soit là sion non mais on est
dans une période de flou voilà on est
dans un moment de reconstruction en
réalité de la gauche mais qui est qui
existent dans tous les partis politiques
en réalité et on a d un mouvement
citoyen qui existent aussi vous allez
interroger tout à l'heure quelqu'un qui
est représente ce mouvement aussi et il
ya une interrogation sur ses poils rôle
des partis politiques
je crois que jusqu'à présent le parti
socialiste n'a pas été en capacité de
porter une voix forte
justement pour dire ce qui était la
parole des socialistes et donc qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont devoir composer le parti
socialiste aussi peut-être qu'il faudra
régulièrement la question mais il ya
vraiment pas comment recomposer je sais
pas mais en tout cas dire clairement ce
que veulent les socialistes ça c'est
quelque chose d'important
après moi j'ai connu des périodes où à
on nous disait que le consensus n'était
pas possible et abandonné l'intérêt de
la gauche l'emportent effet qu' on
trouve des voies de passage et moi c'est
ce que j'appelle de mes voeux la
primaire aujourd'hui parce que vous
souhaitez cette primaire vos oui elle
est indispensable dire que quand on
regarde les sondages même si les
sondages ne font pas une élection on
voit bien qu'il ya un vrai problème à
gauche dire que on risque d'arriver en
2007 avec une élection présidentielle où
le candidat de la gauche n'est pas
qualifié quel qu'il soit c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas entendable dans une
démocratie
moi je ne peux pas me satisfaire de
cette situation donc on cherche toutes
les voix qui permettront d'éviter cette
situation
une des voies c'est la primaire parlons
de saint quentin en yvelines à présent
les tensions qui restent vives depuis le
changement de majorité
un exemple symbolique peut-être la faire
aurore bergé c'est cet élu de droite
victimes de propos sexistes
vous l'avez soutenu ainsi que les autres
élus de gauche
vous n'avez pas apprécié la réponse du
président de l'agglomération lors d'un
dernier conseil d'agglomération
justement vous avez quitté la salle avec
cet élu de droite d'ailleurs ça ça
cristallise un petit peu les tensions
aujourd'hui je pense que ça alors c'est
un autre sujet j'espère qu'il n'y a pas
que des élus de gauche qui l'ont soutenu
dans cette affaire et qu'il ya aussi des
élites droite qui se sont montrés
solidaires qui est le problème de la
place des femmes en politique et du
sexisme de manière générale après sur la
gouvernance de l'agglo il ya un problème
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas réglée qui
est liée à un contexte à la fois locale
qui est l'élargissement avec des villes
qui arrive dans l'intercommunalité qui
cherche aussi ce qu'est
l'intercommunalité cinq nouvelles
communes jazz et puis des devil qui est
elle a déjà constitué avec une
interconnecté fort qu'ils sont en train
de se diviser et c'est extrêmement
dommageable et on a une gouvernance qui
pour l'instant est absolument
défaillante et qui se manifeste par un
manque de respect en fait le discours de
michel laugier finalement qui affine et
qui a fini par attaquer la gauche si on
affaire qui ne concernait pas le droit
de gauche en fait un montre bien qu'on a
une sur cette affaire de sexisme en
voilà qu'est ce qui montre bien qu'on
est dans une période où en fait on a un
président d'agglomération qui est
extrêmement faible ce qui ne s'est
jamais vu cirque ont un président michel
laugier voilà indépendamment de ses
qualités personnelles
je trouve que c'est un président qui
pour l'instant on n'arrive pas à tenir
la barque on se fait que l'élection du
président et des vice-présidents une
élection qui a été annulé par le
tribunal administratif pour une question
d'organisation des normes qui n'avaient
pas été respectés il ya eu un nouveau
scrutin ça n'a pas apaisé les choses
parce que vous n'avez pas réussi à
obtenir des vice-présidences ces bons
moments ça pas apaiser les choses parce
que je crois que la droite en fait est
fortement divisée et que et qu'il ya un
problème de leadership qui ne savaient
pas motivée uniquement par le fait que
vous n'avez pas obtenu de vice
présidence vient pas nous nous on est en
dehors dehors bonheur ils ont décidé
qu'on n'était pas que les qui avait
quatre villes de saint quentin qui était
partie négligeable
dont acte mais en réalité derrière tout
ça il ya un problème de gouvernance
globale de l'agglomération on ne
travaille pas sur les sujets de fond on
a d'un côté la mère de plaisir qui en
charge du projet de territoire mais qui
en fait dit pas son temps à dire qu'on
va travailler à 12 ans travaillent pas à
on a un président d'agglo qui essaye
d'être président et qu'il n'y arrive pas
et on a un deuxième troisième vice
président qui parle en deuxième
vice-président qui continuent de croire
qu'il est président la place du
président que ça peut pas marcher
vous parlez de cette nouvelle majorité
qui n'arrivent pas à trouver ce
président qui arrive pas à trouver sa
place et nouvelles communes qui
n'arrivent pas à trouver leur place non
plus les anciennes encore moins mais ce
que finalement c'est pas votre groupe le
groupe des communes qui auparavant était
aux manettes sur l'agglomération de
saint quentin qui n'arrivent pas à
trouver sa place dans l'opposition aussi
tout simplement non mais aujourd'hui il
ya moins de communes de gauche l'arrivée
des nouvelles commandes et on s'est
adapté avec meetic et votre place il ya
une réalité arithmétique emmener les
villes de droite sont majoritaires
ce n'est pas d'hier que les villes de
gauche n'existe plus tiens un monde et
il faut trouver quand même on est dans
un opci l'établissement public de
coopération intercommunale donc dans
tout les opci de france il y a abandonné
des gens qu'ils sachent soit autour de
la table car il a travaillé ensemble on
n'est pas normalement dans une logique
partisane qui attendait une ligne
politique qui l'emportent ça va de soi
mais que tout le monde travaille
ensemble et se fassent entendre là il
n'y a pas de respect en fait il est
simple dans le dialogue de sourds parce
que du côté de la majorité c'est les
mêmes reproches savent que la main je
vais avoir un discours partisan
également c'est quoi la majorité
aujourd'hui c'est c'est ce que dit
monsieur paul goude quand il annonce par
exemple qui a 5 millions qui vont être
mis dans la piscine de maurepas dans la
presse alors que se disent par exemple
ce sujet là n'a jamais été évoquée n'a
jamais été tranché mais même par la
droite vient le problème c'est pas que
nous on n'est pas les informations c'est
que la droite allemande n'a pas
d'informations on essaie juste pas
entendable cirque on est dans un système
qui normalement fonctionne de manière
démocratique dont il ya des décisions
qui doivent être prises par délibération
de manière démocratique pour l'instant
c'est pas le cas on a un vice président
qui touchait coûte 10 ben tiens on va
mettre 5 millions ha oui et pourquoi et
quand est ce que ça a été décidé et non
mais vous imaginez bien que ça devrait
passer de tout cela devra passer de
toute façon mes professeurs parce que
monsieur faugoo seul à décider
c'est lui qui gère l'agglo même présenté
ensuite je sais pas si la décision sera
présenté est ce que michel laugier a
acté qu'à un moment donné on était 5
millions sur la méprise sur la piscine
ne mord pas moi je ne sais pas si c'est
bien c'est pas bien est-ce que les
piscines doivent être un terminal c'est
un vrai travail travaillons au lieu de
faire des annonces comme ça parce que
monsieur fau booth a décidé que moi
lui l'a dit le niger en fait les
piscines et j'ai trop légères le prisme
y gère l'économie verte ou et j'ai rien
contre les critiques aujourd'hui se
concentre sur le maire d'elancourt non
son absence due à l'absence d'un vrai
président qui dit woods
nous on ne conteste pas abandonné
l'autorité d'un président qui dit où on
va après en avoir délibéré
collectivement pour l'instant il est
incapable de faire ça je voudrais juste
pour conclure et faire réagir sur un
autre sujet c'est celui de l'aménagement
la question du quartier des bécanes par
exemple quartier de la verrière la
verrière avait proposé présenter un
projet l'agglomération s'y opposent
oppose son veto et parle d'une
urbanisation trop dense mal pensée et la
verrière aujourd'hui demandent à l'état
d'intervenir savent que le sujet c'est
pas ça c'est qu'un randonnée de l'agglo
accompagne le projet jusqu'à ce que
monsieur faut qu'ils disent nous on en
revient au maire de la réalité à
seyssins excusez moi de dire la réalité
la réalité ces quinze années la garde et
le site de saint quentin dans les grands
projets de saint-quentin ya le site des
bécanes et un moment donné donc ça veut
dire que c'est l'agglomération le porte
enfin si c'est sur le site c'est que
l'agglo mer sur le port près le projet
plus elle discutait aussi sur le fond
2009 qui est en danger parce que là
c'est pas une opposition à cette
urbanisation c'est un autre projet
savent clairement donné le maire
d'elancourt d un homme ya trop de monde
ne me suis pas d'accord et de quel droit
ils et qui pour dire ça donc un moment
donné la ville de la verrière et ça
correspond à une défiance généralisée ce
qui veut dire qu'en fait nous d'un
coopération et fragiliser la ville de la
verrière mais c'est le cas d'un certain
nombre d'autres villes 10 puisque c'est
ça puisque l'agglomération n'est pas en
capacité de gérer l'aménagement du
territoire alors que c'est que sa
compétence la compétence aménagement sur
cette zone puisque nous en avons la
possibilité on va leur donner à l'état
dernière question quelle sortie de crise
puisqu'on peut par l'écrivain à vous
entendre qu'elle forte crise vous
imaginez aujourd'hui comment ramener les
choses à la raison un mais nous on n'a
pas la main pour ça nous on est on peut
faire que de l' alerte pour dire
attention il ya il ya quand même un beau
territoire il ya un territoire qui est
puissant qui peut faire plein de choses
cette puissance elle se résume pas
simplement la ryder cup où quelques
opérations de com il ya un vrai projet
de territoire
alimentée à construire je pense y avait
un certain nombre d'élus de droite qui
sont prêts à ça moi j'appelle ces élus à
sortir de cette posture qu'il aurait
imposée est vraiment nous dire voilà
maintenant on travaille ensemble
merci et sandrine grand gant que je
précise bien évidemment que michel
laugier viendra aussi dans les prochains
jours s'exprimer sur ce plateau pour
réagir à son tour avant pourquoi pas de
vous recevoir ensemble sur le plateau
pour un débat les invitations front a
lancé pour la rentrée sur cette antenne
pour évoquer les projets de territoire
avec les élus de saint quentin
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
poursuivons cette émission à présent
avec un point sur la primaire à droite
et du centre en vue de la présidentielle
primaires qui se tiendra en novembre
prochain ils sont douze à espérer
pouvoir s'y présenter parmi eux trois
yvelinois henri guaino vient de se
déclarer estimant que personne n'était
présent pour défendre les idées
gaullistes jusqu'à présent l'ancienne
plume de nicolas sarkozy député des
yvelines veux je cite combattre la
surenchère libérale qui sévit dans sa
famille politique pour pouvoir
participer à cette primaire il devra
réunir comme les autres candidats le
parrainage de 250 élus dont au moins 20
parlementaires d'ici la fin du mois
d'août et pour recueillir les soutiens
nécessaires et ils pourraient trouver un
accord avec un autre député candidat
jacques myard lui aussi élu dans les
yvelines lui aussi souverainiste en
attendant ce dernier poursuit sa propre
campagne écouter malheureusement
aujourd'hui la france a disparu de la
scène internationale en europe elle ne
compte plus face à l'allemagne elle a
fait des fautes vis-à-vis de la russie
et au proche et au moyen-orient
elle a complètement disparu aussi est ce
que je souhaite c'est qu'on paie mon
pays revienne dans le concert des
nations pour dire ce qu'il a à dire
d'une manière libre souveraine et
déterminé et puisque nous parlons des
candidats à la primaire issus des
yvelines rappelons aussi la présence de
jean frédéric poisson député il est
d'ailleurs le seul à pouvoir
officiellement se présenter à l'heure
actuelle en tant que président du parti
chrétien démocrate il n'a besoin d'aucun
parrainage jean frédéric poisson qui
sera l invité du prochain café politique
sur téléphiles ce week-end première
diffusion et samedi à 19h30 les ténors
de cette campagne politique poursuivent
aussi à leurs meetings dans notre
département dont les yvelines c'est
françois fillon qui est attendu le 22
juin prochain à aubergenville autour de
hesse et soutient un autre
sophie primas numéro deux des
républicains dans lé zibeline nous y
reviendrons bien sûr sur cette antenne
au cours d'une prochaine édition du 7 8
politique et du journal seconde invitée
aujourd'hui du 7-8 politique patricia
saint-georges responsable du barde m 78
le par dème pour partie de la
démondialisation bonsoir et bienvenue en
plateau l'antenne yvelinoise du par dème
a été présentée le week end dernier dans
un des cafés de versailles dans les
grandes lignes déjà votre ambition c'est
de démondialiser ça signifie quoi tu
démondialiser sortir de du néo
libéralisme mondial c'est un programme
assez conséquents mais sera-ce tout
moment ou démondialiser parce que
s'extraire d'une mondialisation qui a
été construite année après année
ça semble non pas utopique mais
difficile disons que ça passe d'abord
premier pas par la sortie d' union
européenne accompagné bien sûr de la
sortie de l'euro et il faut pas croire
que nous serons isolé si nous quittons
l'union européenne d'abord il ya
beaucoup de gens en france qui commence
à venir à cette idée à se dire qu'il
n'est pas normal que nous ne puissions
pas décider pour nous mêmes
je prends le cas de la de la loi elle
comme riz par exemple qui a été qui est
directement issue de directives
européennes qui veulent plus d'austérité
plus de possibilités pour les patrons de
licenciés de négocier des salaires à la
baisse puisque le le grand point négatif
me semble-t-il de la loi n qu'aubry
c'est qu'un salarié va se trouver face à
son patron seul sans pouvoir s'en
référer à une convention collective qui
le protègerait l'idée de sortir de
l'europe comme le fait l'angleterre par
exemple de l'union européenne comme le
fait l'angleterre le brésil l'angleterre
a raison vous soutenez
nous soutenons le bric sic bien sûr pour
être tout à fait clair il faut mettre la
fin la fin de ces la fin de l'europe que
tous les pays sortent finalement à ça on
peut pas le dire aussi brute brutalement
je ne sais pas ce qui se passera je
pense que si la france sortait de
l'union européenne louis ça ferait des
bagues je vous le disais tout à l'heure
vous avez présenté à versailles votre
notre mouvement votre antenne
départementale nous avons rencontré à
cette occasion quelques sympathisants
écoutez le au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude si on veut résoudre les
problèmes qui sont posés avec les partis
traditionnels tels qu'ils se sont
constitués au stade où ils sont rendus
le le discrédit total qui est jeté sur
le concept de gauche qui est
complètement flou est galvaudé on ne
sait plus ce que ça veut dire ne permet
plus de s'appuyer sur les forces
politiques existantes pour changer la
société
on sait plus le faire moi je suis
travailleur aux finances publiques je
suis confronté aux suppressions
d'emplois depuis 20 ans et nous en tant
que militant syndicaliste agissant dans
les syndicats on estime que c'est par la
grève générale et la mobilisation des
travailleurs qu'on pourra obtenir le
retrait les directives européennes qui
sont traduites en france et a abandonné
en refusant les directives européennes
on
se posera la remise en cause des traités
européens on comprend en écoutant ces
deux sympathisants qui a aussi une
grande déception envers la politique
envers les politiques
peut-être une déception encore plus
grande vis-à-vis de la gauche parce que
c'est ça qui motive aussi la création de
votre formation
bien sûr le la gauche c'est quoi
maintenant la gauche est ce qu'on peut
dire que le ps qui est au pouvoir fait
une politique de gauche
franchement pas il continue la politique
précédente de droite
on peut me pourrait même dire qu'il qui
la rend pire c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui vous dites avec le par
dème que le clivage gauche droite qui
n'a pas de sens non il n'a plus de sens
malheureusement j'en reviens à votre
ligne directrice sortir de l'euro de
l'union européenne c'est aussi une idée
qu'on retrouve dans une autre formation
l'upm l'union populaire républicaine
par exemple pourquoi pas vous rapprochez
pourquoi pourquoi un nouveau mouvement
nous avons des points de dissensions
avec le ter entre autres l'upm dit qu'il
sortira de l'union européenne grâce à
l'article 50 croire qui fait qu' il est
dans les traités cet article mais il
faut négocier avec l'union européenne et
ça peut prendre deux ans pour vous il
n'y a pas de négociation possible non il
n'y a pas de négociation possible
si j'avais dû texte à respecter mais au
moins on doit on peut pas décider de
manière aussi simple de quitter l'union
européenne tout à fait si notre candidat
a été élu à la présidentielle
le soir de son élection il dirait la
france sort de l'union européenne il ya
des traités il ya des clauses dans le
traité de vienne je crois je pourrais
pas vous ne citez de tête qui permet
tout à fait ça non respect
si le nom je vous dirais c'est très mal
donc c'est pas mais en tout cas on aime
et on sort de l'union européenne le soir
de l'élection présidentielle c'est notre
candidat qui l'emportent puisqu'il y
aura si vous réussissez à réunir les
parrainages à un candidat pour pour le
par dème il y aura forcément des
conséquences un retentissement auprès
des autres nations et ça veut dire qu'il
faut accompagner aussi tout ça de
mesures protectionnistes pour le pays un
protectionnisme raisonné
disons que le soir de l'élection nous
nous inspirons du du programme du
conseil national de la résistance
c'est à dire qu'il faut le soir même
occupé les bancs que les que les
salariés des banques occupent leurs
banques qu'on ferme provisoirement les
frontières pour évidemment pour que les
capitaux ne s'en aille pas immédiatement
et qu'on trouve très vite une manière de
créer des emplois alors évidemment il va
falloir on si on revient au franc on
évaluera mais ce qui va beaucoup nous
aider c'est que nous allons faire défaut
sur la dette
et ça c'est un geste politique fort mais
ça rapporte beaucoup d'argent à l'état
c'est à dire si on ne paye plus une
grande partie des 50 millions d'intérêts
de la dette nationale
ça fait des sous pour faire autre chose
pour faire du social
ces mesures protectionnistes qu'on
évoque c'est aussi les mesures qu'on
retrouve au front national au front de
gauche oui comment vous situez par
rapport à ces deux formations alors que
le front national n'ont franchement pas
nous n'avons absolument rien à voir avec
le front national
je pense que le front national
représente disons le capitalisme
français et nous nous sommes
anticapitalistes
nous sommes pour lutter pour les classes
défavorisées contre les classes
dominantes
ce n'est pas du tout clair dans le dans
le langage du fn et d'autre part
disons qu'il flatte dans la population
un certain racisme vis-à-vis des
immigrés ou des des fils d'immigrés et
ça nous paraît saha tolère donc ça c'est
votre positionnement par rapport au
front national ou à leur part au front
de gauche pour continuer à situer un peu
le rapport au fond gauche si le front de
gauche avait un programme solide n'y
aurait pas de problème mais quand on
écoute monsieur mélenchon n'en voit pas
très bien ce qu'il y a derrière son
slogan de la france de la france
révolté la france a soumises
vous avez évoqué l'élection
présidentielle avec un candidat en tout
cas c'est ce que vous appelez de vos
voeux pour 2010 est est-ce qu'il y aura
des candidats aux législatives également
et notamment son département des
yvelines
il y aura probablement il y aura de
toute façon des candidats aux
législatives probablement 1 dans les
yvelines un ou plusieurs
nous ferons l'annoncé officielle de nos
candidats à notre université d'automne
qui se passera au mois début novembre
aujourd'hui que représente ce mouvement
le pardonne pour les yvelines où vous
lancer cette antenne et puis peut-être
aussi sur un plan national parce que
vous vous lancez pour 2017 mais n'est
pas déjà trop tard vous avez déjà
suffisamment de soutiens de poids
nous n'avons aucun poids sauf un
programme solide très travaillé très
concret et c'est là où je vous remercie
de nous recevoir et qu'il faut qu'on
fasse connaître un programme que nous
avons abordés dans les très grandes
lignes et qui est à retrouver sur sur
votre site internet bien évidemment et
puis nous aurons l'occasion de vous
recevoir à nouveau ainsi que l'éventuel
candidat ou candidate qui sera présent
sur le département des yvelines pour
2017 parce que bien sûr sur tv fil pour
vous pourrez suivre la campagne des
législatives au quotidien sur notre
antenne à partir de la rentrée prochaine
merci patricia saint-georges d'être venu
c'est la fin de cette édition du 7 8
politique à revoir sur notre site
internet les programmes se poursuivent
sur tv fils
merci à vous une nouvelle fois